I hope the whole house will forgive me
if I say that standing here I have a
distinct sense of deja vu but today's
vote is an important
well I intend to repel against all of
those who don't want to vote to deliver
brexit
mr. speaker today's vote is important
the eyes of the country no actually the
eyes of the wider world are upon us
today
and every member in this house has a
responsibility in the decision that they
will take to determine or whether or not
they are going to put the national
interest first and not just an
ideological or a single issue or a party
political interest but the full wider
interests of our constituents and as we
look at this as we look at this issue it
is something the decision we take
tonight will determine not just the
future of our country our the future
lives of our constituents but I believe
the very future of our politics because
we have today to take a key decision and
it's simple do we want to deliver brexit
do we want to deliver on the result of
the referendum in 2016 well we know we
know the views of the Scottish
Nationalist Party they they reject
results of referendum they
[Applause]
when this House voted overwhelmingly to
give the choice of our membership of the
EU to the British people did we really
mean it when we voted to trigger article
50 did we really mean it when the two
main parties represented in this house
stood on manifestos in the 2017 general
election to deliver brexit did we really
meet I think there can only be one
answer to that and that is yes we did
mean it yes we keep faith with the
British people yes we want to deliver
brexit because if know there's a if if
the right honourable lady we'll just
wait for a minute because if this
Parliament did not mean it then it is
guilty of the most egregious contract on
the British
they're happy many views across this
house I want to say simply to some of
the groups involved there are those some
of whom believe passionately and have
believed for some time others who have
come to this more lately that there
should be a second referendum I say
simply this you cannot have a certain
can referendum simply because some
people don't agree with the result of
the first I don't I don't like oh there
are many people who want to speak so I'm
going to carry on I've taken many
interventions and questions across I
[Laughter]
don't I don't like referenda but I think
that if you have one you should abide by
the result that people have given you
then there is the Labour Party front
bench and I've heard much from the
Labour Party front bench over the last
three years about the importance of
protecting jobs of protecting
manufacturing of protecting people's
livelihoods if they really meant that
they would have voted for the deal
earlier
now is their chance to show whether they
really care about people by voting for
this field tonight in this house this
afternoon I hope mr. speaker in this
House of Commons and then I say to all
of those across this house who say they
do not want No Deal I've said it before
I've said it many times I hope this is
the last time I have to say it if you
don't want No Deal you have to vote for
a deal out for certainty people want
certainty in their lives investors want
to be able to invest and want the
uncertainty to be got rid of they want
to know that this country is moving
forward if you want to deliver back sit
if you want to keep faith with the
British people if you want this country
to move forward then vote for the deal
today
[Applause]